sorry guys this is part two of why it's
evil to tell men and women that were
equal because women need guidance
now the reason that I was thinking about
this is because I was thinking about how
much I've stressed the past like two
weeks on just what I want to do
because basically I live in London now
I'm from America
I prefer America
however London's kind of starting to
grow on me and I used to hate it that
was the funny thing
and I was thinking so I'm going to the
U.S for 10 days about roughly
and
um
all week I've been trying to think about
where in the next 10 days I'm gonna go I
know I'm gonna go home
and I was thinking maybe one or two
other cities
and then and the reason I wanted to go
to other cities is while
my dad's giving me a free office
building in the in Chicago
um I'd get to and my main reason for
wanting to move home was because I
wanted to spend more time with my dad
and my brother
and I realized I gravitate towards both
of them because they both offer me a lot
of like guidance and I really create
like I think it really helps us as women
when we have guidance and I think we get
pretty stressed
and now where am I going with this
my point is that for the
the 10 days and even for the move
I was leaning towards just moving home
being close to my dad and my brother
but sometimes
I think well maybe I'll move to
and you know insert City Nashville you
know my managers in Nashville I was like
well I could Vegas I actually really
liked it's very up and coming there's a
lot of space there
um then there's Florida my parents have
a house in Florida you got you guys see
it's like I'll start to think about all
this stuff
and it makes everything just so up in
the air and then I get stressed out and
I was thinking about it and I'm like
I'm like should women even be making
decisions
and I think I handle decisions better
than a lot of chicks do but I was even
thinking how
I'm starting to kind of like London
maybe I'll stick around I don't know I
just
my plan was to move home but
no I like America I need to go back to
America but you you guys see the point
so
my point is I think
in a proper world like in a non-feminist
like proper World women wouldn't really
have to make many decisions and the
feminists will come in and say oh well I
want to make all these decisions
but then we see what it kind of does to
us and when we are making a lot of
decisions it stresses us out a lot more
than men like men will just make like a
cost benefit analysis they'll be like
there's the pros of each cities in the
car
me I'll get all of my feelings and be
like well I kind of like I kind of like
it here now and that's the hard thing
about moving is like
you start to like build a community and
then you just you gotta go again
so
I don't know I've just been thinking but
let me know what you guys think in the
comments
um
maybe I'm crazy but I was just thinking
I don't think women naturally are like
inclined to make a lot of decisions I
think it's not like good for us and I
think we're meant to get guidance from
Men
I don't know like the video guys but oh
but but I'll tell you what's even more
evil too is what they've done is they've
made the men into women where they're
very emotional men and most men are
Guided by their wife or their mother
which also leads to destruction and then
you have women following men that are
Guided by their wife and their mother
yes but let me know what you guys think
in the comments like the video subscribe
bye